there are times we will be working with
footage and maybe the footage is super
high-resolution maybe it's like 8k
footage it's coming in as a red file and
it's extremely clunky with your machine
your machine can't keep up with it how
can you work with it in a quicker easier
way well the answer is a proxy and what
is a proxy so let me find reveal this
footage in the project window there it
is so all I have to do is right click
and go to create proxy and I can create
a still I would just want to work with a
still within my After Effects project
file or a movie I can also make sure I'm
highlighted here file create proxy here
same thing still a movie so I'm going to
create a movie and what it does is it
automatically creates a composition it
put this footage in a composition with
the same settings
it created a render queue here and it
says it's going to default to draft
settings and it's going to also default
to a custom quicktime output module and
I've noticed that by default After
Effects creates the output module
animation for a proxy which I don't want
to work with I want to work with a Apple
ProRes 42 file what that's going to do
is to create a very small file size you
can change this to whatever you want it
to be bottom line is you want to be very
draft quality and a lower bitrate file
so that it will playback on your machine
just fine so from here you would save
where you want the file to save to and
worry once you have it set up where it's
gonna save all you do is just hit render
so as soon as this proxy is done
rendering what's going to happen is a
little box is gonna appear right up here
next to the footage and that's how we're
going to know it's a it's a proxy so
there it is so there's a little box and
I don't if you notice that the footage
here changed quality so I'm actually
just going to delete this off my render
queue I don't need this composition that
was created and if I come back in my
proxy here here
my footage here's the proxy in my
timeline how do I know it's a proxy well
if I come up here and I click this
little box next my footage watch the
quality of the footage here watch how it
changes there is the original there's
the proxy the proxy is draft settings
like I said it's pro res 4 to 2 very low
quality original proxy so now I can
really scroll through my footage here
it's going to playback really quickly
it's gonna be much easier to work with
versus the high res footage once I go to
render and let's say I set this to add
to render queue I'm ready to render it
out if you go into your settings here
you're gonna see there's a setting for
proxy use and by default it proxy use is
set to use no proxies so you don't have
to go back up here and turn this off to
make sure it renders out full resolution
it's going to automatically by default
not use your proxy and use your full res
file instead now if for some reason you
want to render out your proxy all you
have to do is change this to use all
proxies and you are good to go so that's
how you use proxies to really speed up
your workflow it's a it's a killer time
saver if for some reason you want to
change your proxy or you want to get rid
of your proxy altogether you can set
proxy you can select file from here you
can go select a different proxy file if
you want to turn it off completely
select none the box is gone you're back
to full resolution footage pretty simple
killer tip